Speaker 1: I want to follow up about this
bigger story through covid that we're seeing
of conservative radio hosts
and mask advocate radio hosts,
anti vax radio hosts dying of covid after
bashing vaccines. Business Insider now reports
at least seven conservative radio hosts and
high profile anti mask anthrax advocates
have died from covid in recent weeks. Radio hosts
Bob Enyart, Dick Farrell, Phil Vallentine and
Marc Bernier, as well as former CIA officer
and conspiracy theorist Robert David Steele
A.M. Caleb Wallace and South Carolina
Republican conservative leader Pressley Stutts
shared conspiracy theories about VAK theories
about vaccines. Before catching covid, they
told supporters misinformation about the virus.
They held rallies in opposition to mask mandates.
As covid cases continue to search, nearly all
of the deaths are among the unvaccinated, and
misinformation remains widespread. Remember all of
these stories we talked about? Bob Enyart refused
to get vaccinated before dying of covid. He had
a show called Real Science Radio. He died Monday.
Dick Ferrell from Florida radio host advocated
against the vaccine on Facebook before his death,
said the vaccines were bogus, said
Foushee was a power tripping, lying freak.
He died of covid. Phil Valentine, we covered
extensively who actually became a vaccine advocate
after being hospitalized. He didn't make it. Phil
Valentine died. Marc Bernier, we covered another
Florida right wing radio host set on air. He
was against vaccines. I'm not taking it. Are
you kidding me, Mr. Antibalas? Jeepers, he died
of covid former CIA officer Robert David Steele
spread covid denial conspiracy's.
Throughout the pandemic, he died from covid
over the it looks like the last weekend in August.
This is not fun. It's not funny. It's it's sad
and it's happening to people that listen
to these folks as well. Caligula's A.M.,
who protested covid safety measures, spent a
month in the hospital, only 30 years old and died
called covid tyranny, called Lockdown's In
masks covid tyranny. By the way, another
important detail, he started showing symptoms
in July and treated himself with ivermectin,
vitamin C, zinc, aspirin and an inhaler. None
of those things shown to actually work for covid
Pressley Stutts 64 year old South Carolina
conservative group leader died after making
fun of mask's. Chair of the Greenville Tea
Party made false statements about the virus,
downplayed the importance of mask wearing.
So listen, in terms of hierarchy and reach
and audience, these are relatively low level radio
people, right? I mean, they were they seem to have
been true believers. They've now paid a price.
The larger audience, people, you know, Hannity,
Tucker, Laura Ingraham, Glenn Beck, people like
that, they strike me more as being con artists.
I think, particularly given the revelations
that Fox News is vaccination and testing program
is even stricter than the one outlined by Joe
Biden. And yet, Tucker and Laura, they keep
working there. My sense is that the Fox people
aren't really true believers. They are grifters.
These guys really seemed to be true believers.
And you even saw them change some of them,
like Phil Vallentine when it started getting
really, really bad. Unfortunately, even these
deaths may not convince people of stuff. If you
go on the right wing enclaves online, you will
see people writing. These guys were murdered
because they spoke out against the vaccine.
It's an unfalsifiable claim, right? Well, it looks
like if you're unvaccinated, you're more at risk.
And look, now these people died. No, no, no,
no, no. They were killed by the conspiracy
goes because they spoke out against the vaccine.
There is no convincing a lot of these people,
but hopefully these deaths are not completely in
vain. They are senseless, but they are hopefully
not completely in vain in that some people will
have been convinced to get vaccinated as a result.
I don't know if that's the case. Let me know your
thoughts. You can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. Welcome back to the show, remember that we
are primarily funded by individual members through
The David Pakman Show membership program, you
can sign up really you it's not other people I'm
really talking to you. You can sign
up at join Pakman dot com. You can use
the coupon code better. Twenty
one to get a discount off of the
membership. And of course you will get instant
access to the bonus show access to commercial
free audio and video streams of The David
Pakman Show and so many other great things